I am going to start off with my sincere
overly sentimental questions before I
get to the silly stuff first I want to
ask you both about working with Adele
because this is her first features
director yeah I have a very good feeling
there will be many more on the horizon
so what is something about her as an
actor's director that you look forward
to more actors getting to experience
with her on her future films you know I
think there's always something very
special about being in someone's
directorial debut because you know this
is the first time they're wearing that
hat and the fact that we get to be The
Ensemble uh enjoy ride that that
experience did for the first time it was
such a bonding experience the trust
between the actors and the director and
the producers to play around and to you
know uh challenge ourselves I think
Adele kept the heart in it
um which was very important for the
entire film especially for Manchester I
think that um
the thing about like having a directory
debut or like people who are playing
leads for the first time in a big Studio
film is like you're there's no way you
can understand it until you've
experienced it so we're all learning
together and to watch as she was like
okay what are you like so collaborative
and also us being like what do you want
like is it okay and then all of us being
like wait let's all figure out like oh
I'm allowed to say for the first time
like what I think should be happening
and it's gonna be listened to and she
felt the same way and just all all of us
learning together really did feel like
group project in a way and I really
think that um Point gray taking a chance
on somebody who's a directorial debut in
that way and like her being one of the
creators of it but I do think a lot of
most of the discussions I had with Adele
was very like at the end of the day this
is a raunchy comedy as it's being sold
but like the thing that takes people's
breath is like the Friendship that's the
core of it and like the journey with
Audrey in which she has to figure out
about her identity and what she like
goes through in it and I think that
um Adele was so great as a as a writer
and as a Storyteller of being like okay
let's not lose sight of that because of
jokes and I really appreciated her for
that that through line in the movie is
definitely like it's fun watching it but
that's the thing that makes it stick
with you well afterwards well that's the
thing too it's because we've always been
the butt of jokes you know and so in
order to be like okay great we're making
jokes on ourselves and we're the butt of
the jokes but also there's something
more meaningful here like that was so
important for all of us yeah there are
some good jokes but first my most
sentimental question of all I've gotten
in the habit of asking this a lot
because I don't think anybody in this
business tells themselves good job
nearly enough so for each of you can you
tell me something you did in this movie
that makes you say to yourself damn I am
proud of what I did there and maybe
we'll give you confidence on future
films and shows oh my gosh oh that's a
really cool thank you thank you very
much for referring we love we're really
bad at that too we do that for each
other yeah words of affirmation in words
um you know a standout for me was my day
with Baron Davis this was like a long
day uh hours and hours of just him being
game for everything I threw at him and
he was such a good sport we had an
intimacy coordinator on set of course
for his benefit and
um the sex noises uh that I do and just
slapping him and like you know all that
stuff like that was just so fun we never
get to play like that you know um yeah
that was definitely a stand-up for me I
think you know everybody behind the
camera and around the camera I trusted
you too yeah to just like do your thing
yeah yeah what about you
um
I think I'm still working on it I think
I'm like just the owning the fact that I
really I've never been a Title Character
I've never been the number one on the
call she'd have never
um felt like I had I didn't have to rush
through a scene because we have to get
to the protagonist store part of the
story so I think that really just like
processing processing that still
um and realizing that that's important
that's okay is like when I'm I don't
know I'm glad that I woke up every
morning and did the best work I could I
guess like you know I don't think I I
don't think I I I watch it and I don't
think oh I wish I would have done that
or I wish I would have gone really gone
for that like I really think we all just
were like here's what it is it might be
our only chance ever so let's just do
100 yeah hurry up and process and let it
sink in because there will be more on
the horizon I'm sure that all right
silly questions time because I play an
acting Would You Rather game a lot and
there's this one question that I asked
all the time and it feels very
appropriate to ask at this movie would
you rather have to fake sneeze or fake
vomit in a scene I'm really bad at fake
sneeze I sneeze all the time I'm
surprised I haven't done it in this
junket yet and I have fake vomited so it
depends on who the we had great VFX
people and they were like what are your
favorite flavors I was like cinnamon
rolls chocolate so my fake barf tasted
pretty good wow I Loki would have been
down I have a small mouth so it didn't
fit a lot so I had to like I have a
really big mouth as the mouthy one I
think probably fake bombing because you
just put something in and then spit it
out versus fake sneeze it's like to make
it
the build up is good was that good I've
heard you sneezed before and I know
that's not real though yeah
that was fake the follow-up to that is
what seemingly silly everyday thing is
most difficult to replicate believably
on set in a film like things like
falling asleep fake driving Oh waking up
is funny waking up always makes me laugh
waking up in the scene you're always
like
like waking up is always so awkward I
guess yeah you know I think I think for
me the most difficult thing is because I
love food I can eat anything anywhere
all you know but it's like when you do
scenes where you're just like eating
over and over I'm like you have to wear
strawberry
for like 87th time you have to watch
what you do on the first date because
you have to commit spit buckets kissing
is also a whole nother thing because
when I'm kissing on screen I'm not
kissing how I kiss in real life well I
can't know my secrets you know I have to
put on this fake TV film kiss you know
what I mean I don't do that a little
suck suck lick you know you kiss for
real you kiss like you kiss intimately
behind closed doors no way yeah everyone
just calm down this is a great question
that I wish I could ask at other junkets
but it doesn't feel right I'm gonna end
with one beef question for you because
there is no doubt in my mind that
certain kill scene that you're involved
in is going to wind up being one of the
best screen deaths of all of all time
this year so when you're filming a
moment like that specifically when she's
pressing the button do you think Naomi
is doing that with the intention to kill
with self-preservation being the top
priority or a mix of both I I think that
for me it's always I I try so hard not
to judge the characters that I'm playing
and really put myself in that situation
I am most easily scared person if I was
in that situation I would have fainted
probably before I could even run there
um for me it's I think there's such a
conflict in that moment of like I want
to help but like what am I doing like
like I think there's would you know when
you've been I've been in life in death
situations when you're in those
situations you're not like thinking in a
precise or concise way
um at least she was not so I don't think
there's any intention but to like maybe
help Maybe not maybe just do what the
director says and the writer says and
Sonny says so
um I think that that's exactly what
happens and which is why there's
probably so much conflict in her by the
end of it of like what just happened oh
my God you know that moment absolutely I
literally sent Ashley a reaction video
my hand over my mouth I was shocked and
you were watching and you said we're on
this
um we're on this episode and I was like
you were on this episode I was like what
what were you a background what are you
talking about yeah yeah uh but I mean I
could unpack that episode for hours
briefly what's your take is because
Naomi just said uh to Jordan oh oh you
want to leave me for her I don't think
she did on purpose I think when
someone's running towards you screaming
do not close it then you're like okay
I'm waiting for you I'm waiting I just
think she does not have periphery washes
how do you know she's never pressed that
right you're right you don't know if
it's a sensitive button I didn't know
what the Panic Room was I didn't even
know people would have those things yeah
no it's all I knew is like pounded the
concrete
my arm and I was like what's happening
those are on stunts we try I believe one
of the most unforgettable scenes I've
seen all I love I love genre stuff so
when there's a good kill like that I'm
like yeah